hello and welcome to a special segment
of game spots play for all we are
talking
madden 21 so i hope all of you are ready
for some football i am joined
by sean grady from ea sports to talk
about madden 21 how you doing man
i'm doing good good to see you yeah you
as well and uh so uh can you
give a little background on your role
with madden 21 and then give a brief
overview of the biggest new additions
coming this year
sure so i'm sean grady i'm the executive
producer for mountain nfl 21 uh
been with the franchise going all the
way back to madden 13
uh big football fan as you might guess
uh some of the cool things that we're
doing this year
we try to innovate on on both sides of
the ball in terms of what you can do
from a gameplay perspective that's the
foundation of our game so we've added
some
uh new mechanics uh with the ball carry
we call the skill set
we've updated the pass rush mechanics on
the defensive side of the ball and tried
to make tackling
a little bit simpler this year as well
to address some of the run meta that we
had
in madden 20. uh in in modes probably
the biggest story space of the franchise
that's quickly becoming one of our uh
most popular
ways to play we did long shot a couple
of years back and then we went more of a
creative player base to the franchise so
we're
deepening that experience and all the
way back to high school and college
and beyond yes there is uh much to think
about especially as it relates to the
upcoming nfl season if we can call it
that
but in terms of madden 21 i got a little
hands-on time with the beta
so i got a taste of some of the some of
the new features but
uh in terms of the refinements can you
break down
in practice how things like the skill
stick
pass rush moves and like the new
tackling mechanics actually work and how
they affect the game
sure uh i'll start with the skill stick
that tends to be the thing that people
gravitate towards they want to score
they want to run the ball
so essentially we deepened the control
that you can do on the stick and added
combo moves to it
so you're still flicking the stick in a
direction up down right left
jukes right and left we experimented in
the beta we actually had a hurdle on
there that you could combo with the
jukes we called it the journal
we've since gone back to that being the
truck stick uh
and you know we'll continue to maybe
refine that as the season unfolds and
then on the back stick we added uh
something we call the dead leg which is
just stop on a dime
let a defender fly past you something
lamar jackson did a couple times last
year looked amazing looks really good in
the game
but just more creative control with the
ability to combo moves together was the
biggest goal there
on the defensive side of the ball with
the pass rush mechanics we really wanted
to make sure that whatever input you
were doing you got clear feedback
so it's back on the right stick which
we've had in years past but the the
the way that it feels better in my
opinion now is you get clear user uh
feedback in terms of the
text on the screen it tells you exactly
what what uh move you're trying to do
and you get an animation that is
responsive the second you try to pull it
off
and there's a little bit of a strategy
with the number of moves that you have
how many times you've attempted that
move with an offensive lineman
that we believe is going to push a few
more players to the defensive
line i know if you see somebody on the
defensive line in competitive play
they're a noob
uh but this this mechanic actually
brings the people off with the
linebacker playing on onto the line
and then on tackling really it's this
idea of a breakdown tackle where you use
the the a button on
uh microsoft or x on sony and uh
it's if you're in the open field and
you've got to make a tackle
you use the a button to kind of ready up
if you see defenders do this in the real
world where they kind of get in position
they wind their feet and then they make
the tackle
that a button is kind of a conservative
way to apply that animation to make that
tackle
i think a lot of the a lot of
refinements are are necessary from year
to year
uh can you speak to how that might
affect the run game because as someone
who
you know what's funny is that when i
play i have friends who just chuck the
ball downfield every down
i like to play methodically i'm i'm
planning out like
uh my play action with my runs and
sweeps and then then i go for a deep
ball and all that all that sort of stuff
but
uh i like to incorporate the run game so
with all of these mechanics in mind
uh can you speak to how this might be
changing up players who who play like
that and use a lot of uh run plays
well first thing i'll say is that you're
a true head coach you strategize that
football's a chess match at the end of
the day
uh so you've got to set up certain plays
to lead to other plays so well done on
your part you're probably winning
against your friends is my guess
uh i'll say this so clint oldenburg is
one of our
lead designers and producers in this
space and he's going to go into deep
detail about all the kind of nuanced
things that we've done to improve
tackling of ai pursuit angles
engagements out of blocks that are all
going to
impact the run game and the run meta
that we saw uh last year
and then when you couple that with the
mechanics that i talked about this year
that are obviously more
user-based the intent is to have more of
a simulation
uh experience frankly more sim football
and more of a balanced
experience so that players like you and
others uh are you know
the the best example is we don't want to
see competitive matches where somebody's
just running
the entire game to win i don't know if
you were you were doing that yourself
but yeah i mean in real football you've
got to be a bit more balanced and i
think all the things that we're bringing
to 21 will deliver that
if i recall correctly you're trying to
make
not necessarily nerf qb's but also but
just make them more
situationally uh in tune with how
people are playing such as you know
cross chest passes so you can't
be a hundred percent accurate if you're
throwing to the opposite side of the
field if you're scrambling one way
uh can you go a little bit deeper into
how you how you've refined
uh qb play in madden 21 yeah i would say
that you're right we're not trying to
nerf uh play per se again we're trying
to make it more like the real sport
and uh anybody that's played madden for
any length of time knows that
there are years where people will run
backwards 10 or 20 yards chuck it down
field 60 yards and make it pass and
it's off their back foot and uh every
year we're always trying to chip away at
uh preventing that from happening and
the the x factors and superstar
abilities that we've added
i think allow us to create some magic
moments like that where nfl quarterbacks
like patrick mahomes does pull that off
from time to time and in our game he's
got that ability
uh to do it but not every quarterback
can do it and not every quarterback even
has that ability will do it
uh every time so there is some addition
in the x factors and abilities that
we'll talk more about that will uh
bring some of that nuanced simulation uh
to our to our quarterbacks
we also added things like uh you can
throw out a sack now that was a
you know debated in our in our beta can
you throw out a sack too easily as an
example
and if you do is it leading to too many
interceptions and our opinion
is if you're thrown out of a sack
there's a high chance you're gonna throw
an interception in the real world so yes
you can take that risk
uh but who knows where the ball is gonna
go um and so you gotta make the decision
whether or not you wanna get out of it
um we've also um tuned the dive you know
when you're running with a quarterback
if you get hit in our game you're gonna
take a fumble sometimes we're constantly
tuning that to make sure that it's
balanced
we just want to make sure that there's
no you know overpowered or op
as the kids say on on the streets with
uh with madden qv gameplay
sweet because i was actually going to
ask like how you approach
balancing different types of players
because
you know back in when i played madden
2004 i was just falcons michael vick
i'm chucking it down field or i'm
running 80 yards right off of the
right off uh my first drive of the game
obviously you can't do that anymore or
you can try and maybe you'll succeed but
not as frequently as you could with
michael vick back in the day
but we've kind of seen a bit of a
resurgence in the mobile qb's with
patrick mahomes lamar jackson
russell wilson to extend for many uh for
many years at this point
uh but yeah is that is that how you like
how do you approach
balancing the different styles of qb
play because you know pocket passers
play a lot differently than mobile qbs
and is that like superstar abilities and
like different
types of stats is that how you're how
you're nailing down these different
types of
play styles it is it really boils down
to obviously ratings which we've had for
years and and x factors and giving
certain quarterbacks like the ones you
mentioned
an ability to get out of the pocket
faster than others or to throw across
their chest and still be accurate like
patrick mahomes every year we're kind of
monitoring the league and seeing how
qb's and really any position is playing
and then thinking about
now in the world of x factors and
superstars abilities that
allow us to pay off what those unique
individuals do
uh themselves but always trying to make
sure that there's a counter to it as
well
we don't want it to be that you just put
like some cool new x factor ability on a
quarterback
but there's no way to defend to defend
it and that becomes uh you know
especially like an exploit in the game
can you speak to any uh any changes or
tweaks to madden ultimate team
so matt and ultimate team is really
built on uh content you know we've
uh i think become one of the best kind
of live services in the industry in
terms of like you show up in the mode
and there's there's something new to
chase and and play it at all times uh
so we are gonna you know really deepen
the amount of content that we deliver to
our fans from day one our team is
actually
all working from home right now cranking
out a great
library of launch content we had great
pro programs last year
like the nfl 100 and while we won't have
that exact program we're thinking of
some ways to
marry some of the ideas that our fans
loved from that in
in man 21 uh as well we'll just really
just a deepening of
the great content that our fans expect
on a daily and weekly basis
now the game is still a little bit of a
ways out but can you speak to how
you're approaching monetization with
madden 21 because i know there's been a
lot of player feedback a lot of comments
on it but
is there any changes or tweaks to
monetization this this year uh well the
biggest thing we think about with
monetization is making sure that players
have
uh the ability to earn everything that
they they want in the game through play
so our most engaged players you know an
ultimate team right now can build
uh the roster of players that they want
uh over time
but some players don't have as much time
and they want to get to the things they
want to get to faster and they choose to
monetize so uh
that um i think approach has served uh
us and our players well that full range
of spectrum of players that can engage a
lot those that can't
engage as much and so we'll stay the
course with that in your head
okay now long shot was one of my
favorite editions of madden 18 and 19.
of course it was tweaked a little bit
with face of the franchise incorporating
ncaa
and now you're saying incorporating some
high school stuff in there as well
uh how do you feel about your approach
last year and what have you learned from
it
that's going to be reflected in this
year's approach to face of the franchise
well first of all the entire long shot
team thanks you for the nod for the mode
uh that was a tough mode to build so
they appreciate some love there
uh so you know we've taken some of the
lessons learned in terms of storytelling
the way that we flow you through the
game
the the amount of cinematics the
decision making and the branching from
long shot you saw that in some of last
year's game
and we'll continue that in the year
ahead uh college football
was a welcome addition you know people
loved playing
with some of those colleges in a
national championship game
we've extended it back to high school
this year so you actually start in a
high school experience it has some
light customization of your team name
and mascot
you'll play up to two seasons of a
college career we call kind of mini
seasons not a full season
and the opportunity to win a couple
college uh national championships if you
uh have the ability and desire
and then one of the bigger things that
we're doing in the year ahead is making
sure that the production value of the
nfl experience
is deeper and holds up with what you
experience
in you know last year's case college
football but now high school and college
football we wanted to feel
balanced in terms of the the depth and
variety the decision making the
cinematics all that type of thing so
you're going to see that in in this
year's game as well
and frankly this is a aggregation really
of everything that we've built over the
last uh
you know three years of cinematic story
modes and
and you know lessons we all take from
the games that we play uh even outside
of sports
sure yeah uh yeah i think that a lot of
people likened it to
a sort of telltale makes an nfl story
in many ways can you uh
briefly speak to the sort of drama that
will be portrayed in
this year's face of the franchise
yep so you uh come into a
high school experience onto a team where
there's an established quarterback
there's a
an opportunity to take over that uh
position
um the quarterback has a bit of a secret
if you will
that you can choose to reveal or or not
that creates obviously some tension and
drama with that character
that propagates through high school on
into college
uh and into your nfl career and along
the way the decisions that you make kind
of uh
navigate the position you play last year
was a qb only this year you can choose
to go to wide receiver
or half back and then also your
relationship with this character and
where you both end up
at the end of your career you know maybe
maybe you're both uh
you know great nfl careers maybe one is
shortened who knows it remains to be
seen based on how you play
all right cool now uh last question
about modes
is franchise mode i think that a lot of
people are curious about
any additions or changes to franchise
mode can you speak to that
i'll speak to i just released a video
last week that some folks may be
familiar with there there was uh some uh
questions around the feature set for
madden and our fans were asking
uh for more and so what i said at the
time is that uh
we hear you we're working on uh
basically some features and and new
things that we will share as we head
into the launch window both for
our our live services which is
continuous development and madden 21
through title updates
and a long-term road map for mountain 22
and beyond so
it's still too early to get into
specifics of that but uh something that
the franchise fans can look forward to
in the coming weeks
just a few more questions before i let
you go uh how do you feel about patrick
mahomes 10 years
500 million dollars how does that make
you feel man
it makes me feel like we picked a great
cover athlete last year
uh congratulations to mahomes he's an
amazing player it's
completely deserved uh he broke the
madden curse if it wasn't already broken
many times
over and i wish he was playing for my
buccaneers
ah damn yeah uh well hey i mean you got
a got a really old tom brady so
good luck with that but yeah speaking
about like uh
can you can you give any insight on how
cover athletes are chosen
obviously with patrick mahomes last year
is a big deal
and lamar jackson obviously had an
amazing season
at least the amazing regular season but
like is there any input that you have on
choosing a cover athlete
yeah i mean first and foremost you want
somebody that represents the league that
had a big impact in the previous year
mahomes and lamar obviously last year i
think
you guys may have called out they were
mvps and we don't just start with the
mvp but
it it maps well to what we're we're
looking for somebody that really
impacted the league
in the previous year uh we like somebody
that
um is great in the community great for
the sport just a great person
if they like madden that doesn't hurt
lamar is a big fan of man group playing
man
that that's a good thing as well and
then sometimes they map to what we're
trying to do
uh for the game you know if you think
back to madden 15 when obj was on the
cover
one of our gameplay focuses was on
catching and receptions and
and uh athletic catches and he had the
memorable
epic catch against the cowboys i think
was on monday night football and so that
translated well to
our cover story as well so all those
factors kind of weigh in to who we
select
all right this is my last question can
you speak to how ea sports is
approaching
next-gen hardware can you give any
details on
you know cross-gen support or how you're
tweaking the game to
be specifically played on next-gen
hardware at all
i'll say we're really excited about the
opportunity to bring matt to the next
gen consoles we're we're not
sharing our feature set yet the the one
thing we have shared which i think is
exciting is that if you
purchase gen 4 you're going to get an
entitlement automatically for free
for gen five so no need to wait um but
in terms of the feature set well we are
gonna have a unique experience
on gen five and looking forward to
sharing more with our fans here in the
coming weeks
all right sean is there anything else
you want to add before i let you go
uh just thanks to all the mad and
passionate fans out there
we're always listening appreciate all
the feedback and looking forward to you
guys getting uh
your hands on the game in august all
right hopefully we get a season
oh yeah that that too well i mean you
know we gotta
gotta think about that we gotta make
sure it's uh safe for everybody but uh
yeah
if not for that then we have madden 21
to look forward to if we want to get our
football fix so
uh sean grady ea sports thank you so
much for joining me
thanks michael and for all of you
watching out there thank you for tuning
in we can look forward to football later
this year in video game form
on all the platforms including pc and
next gen
so i want to thank you for watching and
we have plenty more content on
gamespot.com to play for also check that
out and we'll see you there
you